first Biden is mumbling and bumbling his
way all through Ireland looking at
castles another adventure today now he
stumbled through a speech in Belfast and
seemingly confused the White House and
the capitol take a look at this
it's hard to communicate just How Deeply
invested your success in your success
the people across the United States are
and those who have been there know it
you know it I'm not making this up this
is real this is it's almost people can
taste it as a matter of fact as you walk
into my office in the in the Oval Office
in the United States capital
guess what you know who founded and
designed and built the White House an
Irishman
an Irish no not not a joke
not a joke
not a joke okay U.S president that's a
joke he also repeated his favorite line
telling people not to jump on multiple
occasions take a look
and I want all of you to know especially
the young people in the audience today
and don't jump okay
oh I didn't see it all the way up there
as my father would say please excuse my
back I apologize
just don't jump over
[Music]
hold on now
not funny
all right today despite the White House
claiming this is an official visit Biden
spent most of the day as I mentioned
going through castles and by the way
often looking Dazed and Confused as
usual as he's being led Here There and
Everywhere and as usual he took no
questions from the press as he sat down
with the UK prime minister whose name he
didn't seem to quite remember but anyway
take a look
heck of a view out there
okay guys okay we're good all right
we're gonna walk out slowly we're gonna
walk out slowly we're walking out this
way we're walking out this way and he's
walking out this way
now listen we're walking out this way
we're moving forward
[Music]
but let not your heart be troubled he
eventually did offer to take questions
from a group of children but he was
distracted by one of the child's Air
Force One toy uh before being redirected
by his son zero experienced Hunter and
you can't make that up now this begs the
question by the way first take a look at
that
any of you guys want to ask me any
questions
what do you want to ask me
oh airport there's your look at this Air
Force One right here
you're dead he's got a question what's
your question
um
[Music]
about it to suggest like what's the
what's the what's that
because the key to success it was a guy
named Jesse Helms from South Carolina
from North Carolina South Carolina North
Carolina and he was a very conservative
guy who was very very not very crazy
about
African-Americans he was all we always
had fights well the key to successful
Hunter is to do business deals when your
dad's the vice president have no
experience needed and do millions and
billions of dollars in deals which begs
now another question why was Hunter even
on this trip now is it normal for a
president to use taxpayer dollars to
take someone under a federal
investigation by his own doj on a
foreign trip and wouldn't it have been
nice to have maybe have invited his
four-year-old granddaughter to the White
House Easter egg roll and Hunt Joe and
Joe Biden have never once acknowledged
their own granddaughter imagine for a
second any conservative that was that
cruel that cold-hearted who cares about
the circle by the way no one cares about
the circumstances surrounding her birth
it's a 4 four-year-old precious girl and
their granddaughter and she's been
shunned that is pathetic and if it was a
conservative you'd hear about it every
day and while we're at it by the way why
is Biden taking this trip frankly it
seems like a taxpayer-funded vacation
and even the media mob they are confused
well they're pretty much always confused
but they're even more confused than
usual take a look
after today's pretty medium sensitive
interactions with political leaders here
I think there's a perception that the
rest of this week is essentially you
know tree planting bell ringing and a
taxpayer-funded family reunion what
would the White House say to that charge
that this is essentially the President
coming to ReDiscover his roots and that
there may not be much substance beyond
that
I would not surprisingly dispute that
characterization uh like I said the
president today is going to have the
opportunity to meet with the prime
minister of the UK I think the president
feels very strongly that there is is
benefit both here as well as in the
United States to Mark the anniversary of
the Good Friday agreement
so Joe is enjoying his Irish vacation
the World by the way is now entering the
most dangerous time in my view since
World War II my father fought in the
Pacific for four years and by the way
that includes the Cold War a new Access
of Evil is now forming right before our
eyes and by the way a new world order it
is taking shape and it is not one that
you should be happy about all of this is
a direct result of Joe Biden's glaring
weakness on the world stage and under
Biden's failed leadership America has
now abdicated its role as the world's
leading superpower and China they are
racing in to fill the void and just this
week the Chinese Army released a video
on state television showing what an
attack on Taiwan would look like by the
way this seems pretty imminent to me and
today China issued even more warnings to
the U.S it seems to be a warning a day
at least not to interfere with their
territorial ambition amid the joint
Philippines and U.S military drills but
don't expect Joe to hold any of them
accountable they sent a spy balloon all
across the continental U.S and and
Alaska and it relayed sensitive
intelligence in real time back to China
Joe did nothing when they threatened
quote serious consequences over a U.S
warship in the South China Sea Joe did
nothing again they have Unleashed covet
on the world they construct blatantly
unfair trade Deals they commit rampant
intellectual property theft but again
your President Joe does nothing how many
more threats is Biden going to take from
China before he finally takes action but
it's not just China getting a free pass
Russia they shoot down a drone out of
the sky or they take one out what did
Joe do to respond nothing what do both
countries have in common millions and
millions and millions of dollars in
business dealings with the Biden family
Syndicate coincidence I don't think so
with Biden giving you know up our
position as the dominant leader in the
world world this new axis of Evil now is
plotting to take over last month China
brokered that deal between Saudi Arabia
and Iran now we see that they're likely
going to do the same thing with a Saudi
Arabian deal with Syria this time if
that happens that shows that Saudi
Arabia has made a decision meanwhile
leaked U.S Intel is saying that Russian
operatives are now claiming new ties
with the UAE in other words the
Coalition that Donald Trump built the
U.S Israel the Saudis the Emirates
Jordan and Egypt is now falling apart
and crumbling before our very eyes Egypt
is now giving weapons to Russia we give
them billions of dollars a year it's
time to stop giving them a penny so make
no mistake these countries they are
making what is a calculated deliberate
decision to side with this new axis of
Evil let me explain in more detail Egypt
Saudi Arabia the Emirates these
countries that had bet on the U.S When
Donald Trump was in charge allied with
the U.S they are now siding with China
and Russia and Iran they see America as
weak and they want to join the winning
side and they're betting that in fact
Joe Biden and the United States will
lose in other words they're betting
against America and they're betting on
China that is a real clear present
danger to all of us in this country and
it is not just our enemies picking up
Biden's weaknesses even our allies want
nothing to do with him look at this
recent visit to China with French
president macron who's happy to throw
Joe Biden right under the bus saying no
we won't get involved if you invade
Taiwan and by the way before urging
Europe to reduce their Reliance on the
U.S dollar China desperately wants that
to be the world's currency on top of
that we're dealing with multiple hostage
crises all around the world you have
Secretary of State wink and Tony blinken
recently confirming that there are still
175 Americans left left behind in
Afghanistan and a number of the
mahastages and remember Joe promised he
wouldn't abandon Americans in
Afghanistan he did and meanwhile an
American is being held in a hostage in
Mexico as we speak tonight and a Wall
Street Journal reporter is being
detained in Russia and he did nothing
wrong so how do we expect to lead the
world if we can't even take care of our
own our military is woke our economy is
broke we have absolutely zero leadership
and courage and the world has taken
notice and they've made a decision China
in particular aligning with Russia and
Iran and now the Saudis and now the
Egyptians and now the UAE that they
think this is their moment to act and
become the world's number one superpower
well Biden didn't get a uh you know he
got a nice tour of a castle in Ireland
today hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else friends